Okay, hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's. It is May 15, 2018. We are doing a Zoom call, and
this is recorded. So we're going to talk about a handy subject that I'm going to try to break down in
Simplify as much as possible. I apologize for times I don't do that quite so well. I was told in a video that I
made a few weeks ago, but it had been simplified a little bit more so I think I'll actually remake that.
To make it a little bit easier to understand. Glikation and cancer is our topic today. Glikation
is something I'll explain just a second. And the subtitle is the role of ages, age-e, does that
stand for your chronological age or birth? But it stands for what this talk is all about. And how it
relates to cancer progression as some new research is coming out. It's quite interesting.
So what are ages? So modern diets are largely heat processed. So we get, we receive ages or advanced
glycation end products. That's what ages stands for. It advanced glycation end product on
split what it is in just a minute. But we receive those exogenously from foods. So like grilled foods
and fried foods and things like that, because they're heated it's a carbohydrate that's heated with
a protein that sugar or carbohydrate that's heated with a protein causes these glycated proteins.
And these glycated proteins become these advanced glycated end products that are very damaging to
ourselves. But you might have read about ages with Alzheimer's disease and Parkinson's and diabetes
and cardiovascular disorders. And that is really a major cause of those things. Cause is a lot of
cellular disruption. Cell signaling issues, meaning that cells go talk to each other very well.
And it affects these receptor sites on cells. Remember receptor sites on cell membranes are how
cells communicate with one another and how nutrients get into cells that how hormones and different
things attach to those receptor sites and turn things on and off of the cell. One might say that the
cell membrane, because it has thousands and thousands of receptor sites for different things,
the cell membrane is really the brain of the cell. If you equate an individual cell with a human
body, what would have to say because of all the information that's taking place at the cell membrane
that the cell membrane really is the brain of the cell, not the nucleus of the cell. The nucleus
is simply responsible for replication. So we talk about a cancer that is taking place. That cell is in
rapid replication. That's what a cancer is. It is really something that's affected the cell membrane
or that process that the cell membrane receptors turn on and off or don't turn on and off in the case
of apoptosis. That causes this replication. So I've said it hundreds of times that anything
that can get inside of a cell that shouldn't like pesticide or chemical could disrupt that replication
cycle of a cell. And that can cause problems. When we talk about ages or advanced glycation end
products, we've always spoken about them in cardiovascular disease in all cybers disease and Parkinson's
and degenerative disorders like that. It's been rarely spoken about with cancers until just recently.
But that's what we want to discuss a little bit. So when we have a glucose, so this is a sugar molecule
that attaches to actually an end product of a protein. If you get this glycodated, that's where the
the glycation comes from. It's from glucose attaching to a protein. And that's where you get these
ages. That's what this is the process that takes place. This could take place exogenously in
something that we eat. So we fry an egg in the sugar in the egg, the carbohydrate,
attaches to the protein and becomes glycated typically at a high temperature. This is the bad thing
about fried foods and about grilled foods. You grill meat and the carbohydrates that are in the meat
attached to the proteins in the meat in a glycated way. It doesn't work as a protein anymore as you
eat it. And these things absorb in this glycated form and can cause damage to ourselves because they
attach to these age receptors, these receptors on the cell membrane that cause damage to the cell.
So that's the process that takes place. And usually it takes time. So though this could actually take
place when you grill a product, it takes time for these to build up and become toxic in our body.
So I said this happens with grilled food and fried food, but this also happens in our body,
not just with the foods that we eat, but this happens in our body, not due to heat in our body,
but due to other factors in our body and just to poor diet. So there's other things that can cause
these ages in our body. Now it's been attributed these ages, these advanced glycated end products have
attributed to age spots and liver dysfunction and all these different things. And some people say,
oh, you have a lot of age spots. So you probably have a lot of advanced glycated end products.
Well, that may or may not be true. There can be other causes to that too. But it definitely does
increase with chronological age and it does increase with any degenerative disorder. As a matter of
fact, it's been attributed to all these different diseases. And you don't see cancer out here at all,
do you? I didn't really look at this too close, but cancer isn't on there. This is what it's been
related to over the years, but just recently these have been related more and more to cancer.
What's taking place is that they found this receptor. So here's an advanced glycated end product here.
This is actually a blood vessel here. And this is beneath the lumen. This is the lumen up here
of the blood vessel. This is the muscular layer known here. This advanced glycated end product could
attach to this receptor for an advanced glycated end product. That's where the range comes in.
And multiple cascade of events could take place. It could cause muscular smooth muscle proliferation
and contraction. So what would that do to a blood vessel? That would increase blood pressure because
you have a smooth muscle proliferation. So you got a stronger muscle around a blood vessel
and contraction of that blood vessel will decrease the lumen and will cause a lesser
flexibility of the blood vessel. So it will increase blood pressure. It changes the calcium
channels. Therefore, causing contraction and you have increased blood pressure. Also, it causes
platelet aggregation, not to get too tacky here, but this is what causes placky. And it even gets worse
because these ages attach to low density lipoproteins, which there's all sorts of different types of
low density lipoproteins. If you've ever had your blood tested in a liver pedal and you're getting
your cholesterol checked in your high density lipoproteins, so those are the good guys. The low density
lipoproteins, those are the bad guys. But really, the really bad guys are the low density lipoproteins
that have ages attached to them. They're oxidized. So you got oxidized low density lipoproteins that are
attaching to the epithelial wall and getting under the epithelial wall and causing foam cells and
plaque formation. This is where a bunch of cytokines are given off and inflammatory markers are
getting them given off. Maybe this is getting a little bit too deep and too heavy, but for
doctors that may be listening to this, this is really how placks form. This is how blood vessels
are damaged. This is how people have heart attacks right here. So how does this relate to cancer?
We're talking about endothelial cells, by the way, endothelial cells are the cells that line
your blood vessels. So how does this relate to cancer? Well, it does relate to cancer in certain ways.
These age molecules bind to their respective receptors. So the receptors on the cell membranes.
So these are called receptors for advanced glycation end products or range. Very appropriate name
there because it causes a lot of problems. And they initiate several a-barate signaling pathways.
That means they initiate some signaling pathways in the cell that we don't want to have. It could
lead to Alzheimer's, pathoscural system. We just spoke about heart failure. And it could lead to
cancer and the proliferation of cancer, notice the castysis. So that's what we don't want to have,
but that's what we're talking about. Because the binding of these rages, those receptors for
advanced glycinated end products, to a gene called the caros genes, it upregulates or facilitates
this HIF-1A activation. Oh my gosh, you lost me, Dr. Gunners. Hold on, we're going to talk about it
in just a second. This HIF-1A reaction you've heard me talk about before, and you've heard me talk
about caros before, because these are very, very important gene pathways that tell us what your
cancer is feeding off of. So if you have a lot of defects on your caros pathway, if you have a lot
of defects on your HIF pathway, and you have advanced glycinated end products, meaning your diet
has been poor, you're eating a lot of sugar, you're eating a lot of fried foods, and your diets just
but a typical America diet, you add those together, you set yourself up for cancer. If you already
have cancer, we have defects on K-Ross HIF and your eating and crappy diet, you're set yourself up
for metastasis. So these age molecules bind to their respective receptors and initiate problems
inside the cell. Let's talk about that. Let's unpack that a little bit. It's a lot of information,
I'm supposed to simplify this, right? So if we have not done your genetic review yet,
this will look a little odd to you. If we've done your genetic review, this goes, you'll go,
oh, I've seen that before, I can't remember where I saw that, maybe it was on a channel too,
this is from your genetic review. So your K-Ross genes, there's actually more, this is all I could
get in the screenshot. Your K-Ross genes are very important in how cancer can be initiated and
proliferated. So your K-Ross genes have to do with how you handle glucose and how glucose is
processed through your body. So it's important whether glucose and glycolysis is an initial pathway
of cancer progression. That's why we look at the K-Ross pathway. Well, you add advanced glycoded
end products to a person that has a bunch of this person, I would say, doesn't. But if this person
had twos and more ones and filling this pathway, which a number of our cancer patients do, then they
have to be even more specific to a more keto-like diet, less fried foods. But these aren't variants,
or these are defects, so this person has, we're only showing a handful of K-Ross genes here, but they
only have of all their K-Ross genes, they only have three of them that have defects. So these top three
have a double allele, double allele, and a single little defect. So I would say this person is not
going to be a candidate for really bad problems with everything we're talking about right now.
But if I grabbed, this is my sample patient, so if I would have grabbed somebody else's
K-Ross genes for this slide, and they would have had twos and ones all the way down,
this would be a very appropriate slide presentation to watch a couple of times,
because they're going to have to follow what we're going to talk about at the end here.
The other gene that we mentioned is the HIF1A gene. Now this person has a number of variants or
defects, see all the ones, the other two's, but there's still ones all the way down, multiple HIF genes.
Now that means that glucose is going to be a major feeder for that person's cancer. Let's
look at that pathway again. So we've gone over this pathway multiple times in previous slide
presentations that food carbohydrates are going to break down into glucose. Glucose breaks down into
this pathway that is skipped here through the arrow called glycolysis. Glycolysis gives off a
couple ATPs, that's energy. Your body's whole purpose, whatever your main purpose is in life,
remember is to make energy. And you do so through glycolysis and through the crem cycle and the
fatty acid cycle, where you're making ATPs. So you're typically making energy through glucose and
you're making energies through fatty acids. That's your typical sources of energy. Now some people's
cancer. So cancer needs energy in order to grow. It's rapidly replicated cells. Oh my gosh, it's
a succulent ATP in order to grow. Now in some people, you could have what's called the warberg effect.
The warberg effect is in some people's cancer. It is fed directly through glucose, through pyruvate,
all the way down through lactate and lactate or lactic acid becomes the main feeder for their cancer.
That's these people that have defects in the HIF gene. So if you have a lot of defects like this
person in your HIF gene, you're going to be more susceptible to this problem that we speak of.
But what this paper is talking about in my entire talk here is talking about, even if a person doesn't
have defects in the Keras and HIF genes, advanced glycinated end products are going to increase signaling
pathways for HIF. It's going to up-regulate HIF. So by need of rage, the receptors for
advanced glycinated end products to Keras. So even if a person doesn't have defects in Keras,
it doesn't have defects in HIF genes. It promotes cancer metastasis. So
this is why, regardless of whether you have defects in Keras and HIF, and when we tested you with
kinesiology or whether your cancer was fed through pyruvate this pathway and lactate acid,
you still know what to eat a lot of sugar. Because if you're eating a lot of sugar,
you're getting an increased amount of ages. So how do you get an increased amount of ages
through eating a lot of fried foods, through eating a lot of grilled foods, through eating a lot of
sugar? So if you're a sugar-holic, grilla-holic, and you have Keras defects at HIF, G defects,
you're like going to be for sure going to be a cancer patient. If you're a sugar-holic,
grilla-holic, with you, I don't have any idea what my Keras and HIF genes are,
well, you are setting yourself up for problems. So as you're going to see in a little bit,
the intervention of this, when we talk about this in a couple of slides, it's
regardless of whether you have defects in these gene pathways to decrease your fried foods
and decrease your sugar is really important. That's why just because you could, you know, you could
hide from a cancer for a period of time, because, oh, my friend has horrible kids,
his horrible diet, but he doesn't have cancer. It's quite possible he's going to catch up to him
at some point in time. So it's best if you are a person listening to this and do not have cancer,
do realize that if you keep assaulting your cell membranes,
regardless of your knowledge of these two genes, you're setting yourself up for possible problems.
Most of the people listening to this do have cancer, many already know what their genes are,
many are already sticky to a diet. Well, why am I learning all this stuff? I don't need all this
knowledge. The reason why you learn all this stuff is to kind of help advance your cause and
give you some strength and willpower to stay on your diet, okay? So we're going to be stimulating
advanced, glycinated in products in our body. We are going to stimulate this pathway. Does that make sense?
So the caros is a molecular on-off or growth and upregulates a group one for glucose transport
and contributes to the warmer effect. All that is a really wordy knowledge for a doctor,
but what it does, it means that it stimulates this pathway in itself. So if we look at a person's
genes and we see they have a lot of caros defects, I say we need to go on a more keto like that.
We need to be more strict on our glucose carbohydrate uptake. Also, if we look at a person's genes and
they have a lot of HIF defects, we need the exact same thing. We need to be more strict that our
carbohydrate intake. We need to be more keto like in our diet. So those are the two. There's other
genes that we look at to give that same definition, but these are two major genes that tell us that
we want to be on a more keto like diet which means a lower carbohydrate diet. That makes sense.
So the binding of these receptor-age advanced glycinated end products to caros facilitates, means
it up regulates HIF activity and promotes cancer metastasis. It up regulates NF-campa beta and
other pathways that increase metastasis of cells. So what do we do about it? Well, this is all about
any knowledge. I don't need to know any of this stuff. I've done a doctor. Well, I'm advancing
your knowledge so that you guys could become doctors and help other people. So what do you want to do
about this? Well, number one, a less sugar consumption. So I don't know if I have caros GDFx and HIFGDFx.
Well, I don't care. You still want to consume less sugar. The less and less sugar you could consume
the less ages you are going to produce in your body. So if we could get our 12-hour fasting glucose
down to 75, that would be a wonderful thing. If you have a glucometer at home, you want to start
checking these things. So most of you have a glucometer at home because you already are a diabetic patient
or pre-diabetic patient. If you're already a pre-diabetic patient, you have a bunch of ages
screaming around your blood vessels. Lower consumption of exogenous ages, we need ages from your foods,
less grill foods, less fried foods. You could Google ages in foods and you'll find a whole bunch
of things that you will look at and go, ah, using lower heating methods. That's why stir-fry with
coconut oil and things like that is a really good way to cook your foods, making soups that have
grilled and fried things. If you have HIF and Keras defects, you have to eat a more keto-like diet,
meaning, so what is keto? Keto is ketogenic. What is ketogenic? You're trying to gain your
energy from ketones and not from glucose. So we're trying to not fire glycolysis as much as possible.
We're trying to bypass glycolysis. If we're bypassing glycolysis, we got nothing running
down this pathway. We're going to starve the cancer if cancer is being fed through lactate.
So if we could block this pathway, we could help that. Now understand, if you don't have Keras
G defects or you don't have HIFG defects and you're already limiting your glucose and limiting your
carbohydrates, then your only intervention is, well, I'm going to maybe not grill as much food,
I'm going to eat things that are cooked at lower temperatures. Nutrients that I could add that block
the range pathway are curcumin. So we use our curcuclear. Curcumin is a great blocker of this,
but remember, curcumin is the activated form of turmeric. Turmeric is a spice. If you're going
to take turmeric and add it to your foods, then it needs to be added with a fat and with black pepper.
So a fat increases the absorption of the turmeric. A black pepper will increase the half-life
in your body. Our curcuclear is already fat, soluble so you don't have to do any of those.
Resveratrol. Resveratrol, where do you get that? And why? Oh, we need to start drinking more wine.
No, you get that grapes. The negative of Resveratrol is it has one of the shortest half-lifes
of any nutrient. I think it's like a two and a half minute half-life. I mean, if I took 50 milligrams
of Resveratrol, let's pretend that 50 milligrams was absorbed into my bloodstream. Well,
two and a half minutes, 25 milligrams are left. So that's the negative of Resveratrol.
However, eating some fruits, a lot of your colorful fruits have Resveratrol in it.
Coursited is another great anti-inflammatory. I could have put sticky denils and some other anti-inflammatories
on here as well. Vitamin C is good. Other nerve-to-stimulated nutrients can be beneficial as well.
There's some nerve-to-products. We have a nerve-to-product that we use a lot. Those are some
interventions. We want to go there. All right. So we are going to end there and
hear some technical data where some of this was gathered. And I am going to open it up,
you know, unmute everybody. So give you fairly wanted to stop lunch, you know, your potato chips,
fried foods, really? After this talk, I am ashamed of this. But I'm muted. So if anybody has questions,
feel free to speak up. Talking about limiting carbohydrates, you mean the carbohydrates like
in vegetables or? So if a person is going, let's say when we do your genetics,
you have, let's say your HIF genes and your K-Rest genes are like much worse than these.
Then we would, yes, we would even count your carbohydrates in your vegetables.
So then that's what a true ketogenic diet is really counting all your carbs in all your food.
So a true ketogenic diet, they're not eating carrots, they're not eating rude vegetables because they're
too high in sugar. So the carbohydrate content is too high. But we're talking about a more
keto-like diet. The truth is, it's very difficult to get into a full ketogenic
into where you're actually burning ketones. So people will say they are in a ketone phase where
they're only burning ketones because they're checking a urine stick for ketones and if they're
spilling ketones, they think they're in a ketogenic phase. The truth is you have to check your
blood ketones and it's very difficult to get into a ketogenic phase. You have to really do a complete
water fast for about three to five days to get into burning full ketones. So that is, that is not
always possible. We're talking about a ketogenic-like diet where we're decreasing. So if a person's
genes were really much worse than these here, we may suggest a keto-like diet that we would probably,
we would take away where the person is with their cancer too. So everybody's an individual,
but in general, we would take away their root vegetables too. We wouldn't necessarily have you
counting all your carbs in your other vegetables, but we would take away your other complex
carbs. So we'd put you on a grain-free diet instead of just a gluten-free diet. So you're really
restricting your carbs. Now, that's very difficult to do that. If a person is below normal weight,
so you can't take a person and put them on a ketogenic diet if they're already below their desired
weight or they're losing weight, that's the difficult part of that. But so everybody's an individual
when we start talking about that. But in general, that's what your question was. Is it general?
Then I would say, no, you don't have to necessarily count all your carbs in your vegetables. You're
really counting more of your carbs in your grades. Any other questions? Yeah, I have one. Regarding the
comment on the HIF gene, I'm looking through my genetic printout that, and I don't see HIF
on here. It's the 2016 version. Who by speaking? My name is Connie Ferguson from Pennsylvania.
So the report that you have does not show the HIF gene. You'll have to let me show you.
Well, you know, I don't see your screen, but later on in the night, I look at it.
Okay, so I have to pull that up separately. So this is so in the report that comes with the software,
it does, nobody looks at HIF genes unless they're looking at, you know, they're doing more
tents like cancer work. So I have to put up in the gene. So there's a way in the software that I could
look at all your genes. So remember, okay, so your version 423 and me, there was about 700,000
steps tested. So each one of these is a step. So in the report that you're given, it's probably only
got maybe 300 steps on specific things. So the different cancer ones like the Keras and the HIF,
and if you have cancer and you've ever gone over your genetic report with me, then we go in depth
to those and we pull those up individually outside of the report. So I think I'm speaking with you
tomorrow or something. Are they cutting? Yes, you are. Okay, so I will pull up 23B again and we'll go over that.
Okay, sounds good. Thank you. Yes. Any other questions? The only thing that comes to mind specific
to this group, I know your introduction was about cancer, but I'm a lionian. We can cover this tomorrow
if you want that to be the version, the venue. But in some of the materials that I've read from your
website, a line will, my words probably not technical for you, but will change its frequency over time.
How often do we need to have a check back with you to make sure that the line protocols we're using on
our right are still the right concoction? So a couple things will determine that. The biggest thing is
how you're doing. So if I have a live patient and they are staying, they feel like they're staying
stable or they're slowly improving, then we may change the frequencies to up how much kill we got
in an overnight program. So live programming for the right is extremely different than a cancer program
because in a cancer program, we could put, we're attempting to quote, unquote, kill the cancer with
the right frequencies. And the way a cancer cell is going to die with, with the knife is going to
stimulate a poptosis and that you will not get any, quote unquote, a hoaxyber reaction from the cancer
cells died. With lion disease, you're dealing not with your normal cell, you're dealing with a bacteria.
So we're killing that. Yeah, and it's a grab negative, which has a lipopolysaccharide in the
cell membrane, and when you kill it, you're going to liberate that lipopolysaccharide. If that's going
to stimulate an immune reaction, that's going to cause difficulty in getting it out of the liver cell,
you're going to have that hoaxyber reaction. So we don't want to kill too fast. So if I
speak to you or with any live patient, they go, I'm doing really well, but I feel like I'm
kind of plateaued, then I'll say, okay, then I'm going to tweak your program, we're going to add
the amount of time that we're doing to kill, and we're going to push this a little bit harder.
If the patient says, if the patient says, so there's three things that can happen, the patient says,
I'm doing horrible, then I might change the dwellable, we're going to go slower.
Number two, they say, I'm doing well, but I feel like I'm plateaued, then I'm going to change the
dwellable, we're going to go faster. Number three, they say, I'm doing fantastic, then I'm going to say,
okay, well, it's not changed anything. Okay, so the frequency doesn't move, it's just the duration
or dwell. Well, the frequency may move because lots of times I'll get some, you know, what I'd add,
some was I maybe do some distance testing, I may add some empty bar, I may add some other
other co-infections. Okay, that may help the person too. So with live, there's a lot of tweaking
that can be done. So whether a person's speed up or they're doing well, we could do a lot of tweaking.
Okay, we'll probably talk more tomorrow than. Thank you. Uh-huh.
Hi, this is Mary Rangel, and I'm taking it, it's the 23 in me that you get your genetic review from.
Yes. Okay, and I have the kit here, so I will get that done and find out what's going on.
Okay, good, you see, to work up some spit to get that thing hold up.
Exactly, so it's good to know, but good. Okay, that's my question. It was all good information.
This is Sharon, I'm a little confused about like when you say the frying and the grilling, but
you can stir fry like, is it just like really fast eating? Yeah, so it's that temperature that you're cooking.
So like when I stir fry, usually put it up high and cook it quick, you know, like to keep it crispy, so.
That's what we don't want. Okay, so cook it slower, and it's going to be a little busier.
Okay, so even you could use the grill on a low setting and not have direct contact with.
You could use the grill on a low setting, but think about it, if you got, you know, you got an open
flame underneath the product, if you have the grill and you have a pan on the grill and your
stir-fried vegetables on the grill, that's fine if you do it on a low setting.
But if you have, if you're cooking meat on the grill,
there's really to get the meat done, you're either going to have to cook it, you know, at a much
lower setting where you're not really fried it so much. And you can still do it, but it would caution
you if you're doing it vegetables on a grill, don't wrap them in aluminum foil. We used to do that,
don't do that. You're just getting aluminum from that too. So use a grill pan of some kind.
That would be the better way to do it. So you get a more even heat, you don't have spots where
the heat's just coming through the, the burders. And understand with all of this, we're not talking
about that you could never grill again or anything like that. We're talking about just the frequency
that you're doing this, that doesn't mean you get, oh, I really like vegetables crispy.
Doesn't mean you can't, you know, stir fry at a higher heat, it'd have vegetables, crispy
sometimes. We're always talking about balance in all of this, right? So that's the important piece.
Now, if I had jeans that will look like I had twos all the way through here and wugs and
there are a lot of defects here, I said, I have to, I would say you have to be more picky with that.
But so it's, but it's about that balance, just remember that. Yeah, just in like in the summer,
we use our grill for like an oven. We don't, you know, we cook it stuff really slow. We have,
oh, yeah, you know, it's not direct flame, but we don't heat up the house, you know. Yeah, absolutely.
We do that too. Okay. Dr. Connors, this is Crystal. Hello. Can we call and set up an appointment and
and just go over the 23 and me again. I don't remember a thing you told me about mine. What?
I thought you had written it all down and you had it all memorized. I have notes, but I don't know
what they are. Absolutely. Okay. Yes. Okay. Okay. Thanks.
Dr. Connors. Uh-huh. Hi, it's Lisa Nagel. Hi. Hi. Same thing with Crystal. I probably will want to
review these gene defects because I don't remember either. But I have a question about,
I get confused with like hummus and chickpeas and sweet potatoes are estrogenic, but they are
are correct. They are. What was that last piece that we dropped a page? Are they phytoestrogens or
they're the good estrogen? Like, uh, yeah, it is confusing. Um, things that have phytoestrogens are
are, uh, can stimulate, can they stimulate bad estrogens in our body? And the answer is yes,
they can. They always stimulate bad estrogens in their body. No, they don't. The ones that I would
stay away from for sure are soy products. Um, but again, if that's a balance, could you never have
soy sauce ever again? No, we're not talking about that. But I certainly wouldn't go purchase soy
products like I certainly would never drink soy milk and I wouldn't go buy tofu. Um, I wouldn't buy
soy yogurt and, you know, I wouldn't buy any of that soy stuff whatsoever. Um, that's, that's the
major thing that I would stay away from. Um, chickpeas and things I would not stay away from those.
There's too many other benefits to those. If you're also, if you're concerned about those and
you have an estrogen positive cancer, you should be taking dim and, uh, broccoli date and even
the fermented soy chew that would help prevent any issues with that anyhow.
And I do. I, all of the above, I just, everything you said, that's exactly what I do. So
it's just confusing because you read about, you know, sweet potatoes and chickpeas and they're good,
they're not good, they're good, they're not good. You know, so, okay. Well, and it's about, and it is
about, remember, anything you read, even in what we talk about on these things, you know, quite honestly,
there's times that I get conflicted in my heart of whether I want to give you guys a talk like I did
today because sometimes I just think that too much information is just gets confusing. And I'd
ever want that to happen that I'd ever want to be the perpetrator of that. Um, because it's life is
about balance. And honestly, in, I see in some of you sometimes that you get a little bit crazy
idol about something sometimes, is that true, maybe? And that's not healthy either. So we are called,
I believe, um, uh, to seek wisdom to not be ignorant. I think it says in the new testament 19 times
last time I come to it. Brethren, I wish that you not be ignorant. And I know Paul is not speaking
about glycinated end products. That's that. But it does say that we're supposed to seek wisdom.
You can see that throughout the scripture and throughout proverbs. But it's not to the point that it
causes us to hybridate on some high mountain, some place. So if what, if what we're doing is causing fear,
we've gone overboard. Um, it's good to seek wisdom and to learn what I just said. Oh, that makes sense.
Now that gives me some a little bit of added juice to snap my diet a little bit and to maybe I
won't grill every single day. And that's the way I want you to take this information. And it also,
you tie it back to the genes. Because if a person, I think I just spoke to somebody today that they had
like no HIF defects. And their Keras genes look similar to this. I would say, hey, you need to
really worry about that. You are already sticky. And I think I said this to this person. You are
already sticking to a diet that is fairly sugar free right now and really decreasing your
um, your carbohydrate said, but you have no HIF defects. And very few Keras gene defects, I'd say, well,
if you're grilling a little bit right now, that is not a contributor to your kids or things. So just
remember that if that life is about to balance. Okay. Thank you. Dr. Carr. Uh-huh.
This is Jane Delaney. Um, talking about the ketogenic, um, weight eating, I think I'm struggling
in getting fat in my diet. And I just kind of wanted an idea of how much fat like tablespoon
of coconut oil a day, like you would recommend. Okay. So in a ketogenic like diet there is literally
no limit to how much fat you can consume. If it's a good fat. So we're not talking about an
Atkins diet that you're eating bacon grease. Um, but coconut oil is something in a ketogenic diet
that really doesn't have a limit. So you are, you are stir frying with coconut oil. You're taking
good oil with uh, in your smoothie. I mean, that person could, if they're on a ketogenic diet,
you don't have to, but I'm saying this is what you could do. I guess my question is like what's
the minimum? Because I don't feel like I'm really getting fat in my diet. And so I'm like, okay, well,
I need to at least get X amount a day, somehow, some way. So what would that X amount be? Because
I just don't think I'm getting enough. So an ketogenic diet, where you could get an increase
amount of fat and make you feel more satiated with your meals is to add nut butters
and coconut oil to uh, like smoothies. Like a couple tablespoons. Yeah. I would plan on what your
goal would be three to six tablespoons of coconut oil a day. Okay. Okay. And you could have three
to six tablespoons of nut butter a day. What kind of nut? Well, a lot, everybody migrates to
peanut butter, but you could have a little bit of peanut butter, uh, but like cashew butter and
all the butter would be good choices. Okay. All right. All right. Are we questioned out?
Well, we're at about 50 minutes. So I think we better shut down. Hopefully this was helpful.
And if this sparks more questions, you know, make sure you e-mail them
in to me right away. And I will keep
flooding you with more information that hopefully does not cause anxiety. So
um, if these, if these talks do cause anxiety, stop listening to them. That would be my
recommendation. So we don't need any more anxiety. Well, what I think is good is you explain the
very detailed version for people who can handle that and then you come to the conclusion for the
rest of us. So. Oh. Well, I try to make, I think the definition of a good teacher is to make
very complex things simple. And I wouldn't consider myself necessarily a good teacher yet, but I'm
trying my best to try to make these things simple. Um, and I think where I, my fault comes in as I
think, oh, I'm going to, to, this is going too long so that I hurry up and I don't simplify things.
Well enough. So I'll keep trying to do that. All right. Well, thank you guys. And. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.